for years the village of chechova near
the town of teslich has been waiting to
be connected to the city water supply
system
savor says a few months ago they thought
their dreams would become a reality and
the water wells in front of their houses
would be a thing of the past
the expansion of the water supply
network had included their village
however the ongoing political crisis in
the country has blocked the continuation
of the project financed by the european
investment bank
nobody drinks or cooks with this water
we only use it for showers and toilets
we have to go to the springs uphill i go
every day to get 10 20 50 liters when we
drink it we go and get it again
the municipal government had planned to
connect two-thirds of the population to
the city water supply by building a new
filter station
the largest post-war project in teslach
was supposed to be completed in march
2023 but it was blocked because the
presidency of bosnia-herzegovina
did not sign the agreement with the
european investment bank that finances
it
oh yeah
this is a direct example of the impact
of the blockade of the institutions of
bosnia and herzegovina which directly
affects the quality of life for ordinary
people and the lives of our people
should be everybody's priority
he adds that the blockade of this
project will affect almost
people
and it's not the only project that has
been blocked
a million dollar fund to help economic
development in areas along the border
between bosnia herzegovina and serbia is
on hold as is an agreement with norway
on financing projects in bosnia's
justice system and approvals from the
japanese government to appoint an agent
to procure equipment for the border
police and hospitals
at the center of the crisis is milorad
dodec the leader of the bosnian serb
enclave republica
a member of bosnia-herzegovina's
tripartite presidency
dodec has refused to participate in any
decision-making process worth more than
50 million euros
because he says it goes against the
ruling of the entity's national assembly
i think all i'm doing is strengthening
the role of the national assembly here
which should be the final place of
decision making not the presidency
it has created a crisis which some
believe will enable dodic to stay in
power
the fact is it's easier to rule over
poor people and it's also a fact that
the municipalities where the projects
are being blocked are the ones run by
leaders and mayors from opposition
parties similar dodec is trying to
suppress the opposition
in tesla another consequence of the
blockade is all too evident
the planned construction of a wastewater
management plant will allow treated
water from the sewage to flow directly
into the usoda river as early as next
year
but that won't be possible without the
decision of the presidency sonia gallego
al jazeera